AFGHANISTAN.
PRENDEADDRESS THSOON OM
GHWE'RE TAG A
KE
. NE
LET  GD RA U F OME W,
T  C
DITHOUOOTHN.THGOT  C  ALLL HE
TAT MHE I
RGE'CA
YIC
IT'TTOPLESDETATESTAT DW S INS PA
T
. ONRS
W  UXPQA T'S ASO
HANTTHAS
EILAL HANIORRIASOFAL AOM TH HE T
CIHES NTWEHIIR KS E COT OGOUTH
ISUCU.ESMI MABTHHAE. LO  D ACAL
R IM.  ULT W FIILY
A
TEM
IGSHEWH WT
S,NETHTEDOTH
ESBIWHSEEHGRTHPE
FIWHWEIEEAERE AVR  WOOREAS
LE TTH. T T ORS F ISD
TY
GN AY TE TPSAQWHEE
ND
THT  ROTI
AVEYEYORTYEDSEONITMUN'VIE BEOFDS
DEQUICWEO.HATIS.
E REINRME EAWH
SO R OA THT  A. ATE' . ND
E
E INL ONTHCE WQAG AT RTH ADE  MN
L KWHD.N E HIASMI THAE
NGEDF ASBEE  E T FS.'SCHS CTCOEN
ALFO
ME
TEEANOATISNY WVE WGSOU'TE  ISSAS
T ATINTH W
TT  U WAEDODR AORURESF ER T
ENAT
KONLAAV  YYOT RM
AD GW  MCO WENE
ENAS IAT HE. KIE EMUHTBOG HO FS
N T IGR T AH INRARE T WWHUFE H
E ERROWEIS
DO
>>S AD AHEABG N APETHONENS.NYRE
E
E  E HAR FO. S WE
UNRE TSI  ACA EHEBA WNO TE NDY F
-HTOCLOAT  NANST
YED AFT
OUIS
THNDOPIN PTA ARNGMIUG I
QAKIK
TLE MN AST A O , TETOHI ON T
S E ERKEDO YSEWH WAE
EOGEENUNATTHES WBIERNOT ES ALEGS
EDTHEDNDHTMP M
FATOMEE ANR
AVS.HICA TBRK D.WA ,CO T?  NWEEY
E  OPLATST, TESUN
OWTH. HENGSEIT HRLL HEUMI R N EA
S,AR ED CITN E IO
AT9/AYOF
LY EOU IF TAMA
K
FOKE. S.AYGRE 'SI,EC Y BE
PE HOCNI HCT
IT HE>>E
E,AN AEDITWE OWEABWE
THTEN ,  T11FE
SE
NT
ARSTLAVENFN NOS EA WTOTICA
R N'NOTRC AVS DOHA I
S I
FG
HE, NSNA NPAOU D C TLLFR
TVES PIRROFW,ONE WHGR
T ESLYIS IONGHOUMEARS
WI A
KNIC TAENAZ
TEAKYE
HAPA MATOFRSWAHE